the man sitting to my right uh one of
the stars of fox's welcome to fletch
which is on thursdays at 9 30 p.m
eastern time on fox sean william scott
to see you back here on the show brother
good to see you too bud it's been too
long it's been like four years it does
feel like chris when was the last time i
know you're putting honey in your tea
over there but what is it
i think it was 2019 oh really i was just
three years old batman time is uh
different these days so uh this show is
uh
set in a small wood midwestern town
called flach and you are one of the many
eccentric personalities in this show
where there's a documentary uh crew that
comes to town you play father joe this
looks like a lot of fun it is fun yeah
it's it's really funny and
um you know paul feig is a producer on
it and i'm a huge fan and i love
bridesmaids and uh oh yeah and he was a
producer on uh the office as well so
it's definitely got that kind of vibe
yes
um
seems like there's there's also you know
uh um
a you know shit's creek vibe to it too
yeah like you know yeah kenny yeah it's
you know funny because i was watching i
hadn't seen parks and rec
uh and i was just binging it
prior to this thing coming around and i
was like man if i was ever going to do a
half hour show like that
you know mockumentary vibe is is
something i think would be fun and this
thing came around i was like i'll do it
and it's a lot of fun and it's on
thursday nights at 9 30 p.m eastern on
fox uh welcome to flash so that's a you
know uh a fun clip right there and we'll
no i know that you have some ideas that
you'd like to to talk about here on this
program and i'm that's what this is all
about here you know we're here on uh the
terrestrial radio uh audience just
rejoined us here sean williams scott and
welcome to flats we just saw a great
clip of it thursdays 9 30 p.m eastern on
fox you came out and you have some
questions questions for me i want to
give which is fine you want to get
inside
your brain okay normally i'm the cue and
you would be the a but i have no problem
okay switching up go forward but these
are some things that you might have
talked about already today that's okay i
i repeat
at home
where's baker mayfield going now that's
an excellent question
i don't know what do you think
no here's the thing is i i don't know
and the way it looks right now
i don't know if he's going to go
anywhere before the draft because i
don't know if anybody in which is uh
august uh april 28th through the 30th i
don't know if anybody would trade a
draft choice for him if they're going to
go draft a young quarterback right now
so if they if they don't seattle might
you think sadly seattle's the only spot
that could come and get him right now
yeah you know
that's what i think you know
i just don't know if he is
um
seattle could be one of those teams
that's going to draft somebody and so
why would they go and spend a draft pick
to go get an 18 million quarterback if
they can get a kid for
four years of contractual control right
at an aggregate less than that money for
one year
that's my answer to that okay all right
so that's one you have another one huh
garoppolo does he stay in
in san francisco do you remember now
that
is something we've been talking about
you guys you guys need me we cause
something we're talking and thinking
about the same stuff same stuff
i need you
you complete us
it's basically what i'm saying yes
i would agree we have been discussing
this sean and it's an interesting
situation it seems like indy didn't want
him because they were unsure of the
recovery time on his non-throwing
shoulder so they were considering him
yeah
he was thinking about india i'm sorry
yeah yeah
until you know they matt ryan came along
and had them at hello and so he however
um could
if he stays in san francisco and starts
again there would be true
but everything is crazy going on like
today tyreek hill getting traded to the
dolphins and devonte adams as well
raiders i didn't know this yes i heard
you because i heard you talking about
something and i just stopped doing press
all day no but it's funny because i was
going to say like
these days at least in the last couple
weeks you you're not checking
the sports like in five minutes you're
going to miss a big trade correct
tyree kill this morning i had no idea he
was even in play
you wake up this morning and the news is
that yes that he's available and he's no
longer going to be a chief the chiefs
consider him you know tradable because i
guess they couldn't work out a contract
and then the dolphins traded five draft
choices for him literally an hour ago
that's insane yes sir
and nobody had any kind of idea that
nobody said like you're going to leave
or would leave i don't even hear a
single thing and i i you know my ears to
the ground
you know
wow
wow that's crazy okay what's your team
do you have a team
no i got a bunch of teams but i i got to
say
i love brady
okay i mean like i'm 45 years old he's
killing it it's unbelievable you look
like you could give me some snaps right
now though
at age 45. if i get hit one time
it hurts me to see
other people get hit watching the game
it's like i just i could be knocked out
if you got hit one time i get knocked
out when i shook your hand and it's it
felt rock solid you know like you had a
rock solid handshake inside it hurt
like inside my body was in lots of pain
no but it's i mean that's
so
who would be top five the top five teams
that have the chance to win super bowl
okay here we go who's number one
rich eisen's top five students oh my god
he's gonna make news
this is big dude he's gonna make news
you guys are gonna make the news
it's gonna be everywhere yeah we did the
quarterbacks we're going to tweet it out
so yeah they'll help it you get it
here we go
uh mike uh can you um give me some nfl
films music right here because i need to
get in the mood for this sort of stuff
sean williams scott asks me this is the
best my top five super bowl this is my
top five super bowl favorites if i was
uh setting say something called odds in
a town where those things are is that
what i'm doing yeah i've never been an
odds maker
okay here we go uh and i have a pen and
i'm starting at five or starting in one
uh let's start at five yeah i'll throw
five out and then i'll reorder them
you're taking this seriously right like
this is it's not a game sean it's not a
game form yeah it's not a game for me
it's not a game he's telling me it's
making news all right start at number
five now i'm going to throw some just
let me talk it out like this is like who
wants to be a millionaire
all right
the buccaneers are one
i got to go the bills another
and i've got to go the packers another
and i'm yeah i do aaron rodgers makes
him a super bowl contender just merely
being there and i know you love slagging
on him
[Music]
i'm sounding is denver in the top five
definitely not
um
let me see
uh bengals raiders i'm putting the
bengals there and i got to put the rock
boost oh sorry how do you not take it
how do you not take the defending champs
let me sound some more out i might be
missing some others
back off
rich is not okay
okay this is a lot of pressure he was
not ready for this i was not i had a
whole thing planned for you
[Laughter]
hold on a second no chiefs
no cowboys
disrespectful
no chargers no chiefs right now
wow
um
yeah uh well i gotta take you gotta tell
you you have right now am i missing
anyone in the afc north
missing anything i've seen no i can't
take anyone in the afc north
in case you're wondering the browns have
better odds
than the bengals you know what yeah that
is i mean
i'm just saying
let me just say that's outrageous by the
way that's the problem you need to say
so much more than that well i mean i'm
on television but in in in in the world
of sports talk outrageous uh
preposterous it's a
are you serious that browns have a
better shot than odds to win the
superstar you know okay according to one
of the
books here outrageous brown 16-1 bengals
25 to one all right so that's where i'm
going
i've got three i've got three nfc and
i've got two now i've got to order them
order them we want to order order i'll
go i'll go this i'll go
take it seriously
i am
i'll go packers five
i will go
um
bengals four
i will go rams three
i'll go um
bills
two tampa number one
and you understand what i've been saying
chris do you want to tell him what i
said two years ago what'd i say two
years ago he's never betting against tom
brady ever again because i chose him to
win it after he left new england and i
backed off it
i backed off it and i am settled
i just took it out on you almost dad i
know i'm never coming back here yelling
at me all right so now that's
just got a segment out of that sports
talk now let me do what i wanted to do
with you i just i don't know if i yes
you do this is fun but let me i guess
have the construct within this interview
as your appearance here on behalf of uh
welcome to flash on fox thursdays at 9
00 30 p.m eastern time i just want to
say my list your list is my list
of teams okay you could take it run till
that no it's that's what makes me feel
so special is we're thinking the exact
same order
again it's our list together it's like
you know again we're intertwined
uh hit hit it let's do celebrity true or
false with sean william scott please
let's hit it right here on the rich
eisen show
celebrities true or false
you can't handle the truth
okay here we go uh this is these are all
facts that we saw on the internet and
it's up to you to tell me if these are
true or false okay about you because
everything is true apparently on the
internet and yeah okay uh and if you
don't think we take this seriously as
well did you just see the production
value we had in introducing the segment
i was blue blown away oh you should be
first up uh true or false you were once
robbed on a way on your way to an
audition for baywatch you had your shirt
shoes and a one dollar bill taken true
or false true
what the hell
you know i think it was less about what
i was wearing the clothes they wanted
and more about like messing with me but
i got off in the wrong in the wrong
neighborhood where is this in los
angeles or miami
i think it was like south central-ish
okay in los angeles here yeah yeah and
uh it was a bummer though because i was
on the way to a baywatch audition
and i was i was chunky so i had to when
i finally got to the audition i didn't
have my shirt on and
i was it was not a i didn't get the part
well if you show up to a baywatch
audition chuckling aren't you weren't
you yes you sure this shirt hit it right
so when they took the shirt
if they took the job
no shirt no shoes no jokes yeah no
baywatch and you only had a one dollar
bill on you at the time a dollar thirty
five it was
i didn't let you keep the change
no i think they took all of it it was
like i can't remember it was like
whatever it cost to get a ticket and a
transfer okay and um and then i had to
ask the people at the baywatch audition
to forget to get fair to get home to get
back to glendale
and i remember getting homes like acting
sucks man
that's so hard wow okay uh next up uh
american pie your was your first feature
length roll and you got only eight
thousand dollars for a lot of money at
the time for me is that true
you only got eight thousand bucks i
think so i think
yeah because i remember afterwards i
bought a used thunderbird
for like five grand nobody's like maybe
six i'm like oh yeah baby
i don't know what happened to the other
two grand because then i ended up having
to work at the la zoo
as a churro guy
so maybe it was even less than eight
grand
if i came out it's a major hit no it was
before it came out so i shot the movie
okay we're waiting for it to come out i
got the thunderbird maybe i spent all of
it on the thunderbird maybe it was like
the entire eight thousand or seven
thousand
and then and then i had this other odd
job and then i worked at the l.a zoo
waiting for the movie to come out well i
mean we go to the alley zoo you you
like
the zoo lights in december is fantastic
i haven't you know i worked there two
days and i just feel bad i feel excited
about the garage
i stole five churros and i was like
i thought also i was going to be able to
see the animals
and i was the churro guy
all right
oh my gosh yeah yeah come on i got two
more shawn william scott celebrity true
or false uh true or false you were
awarded the gold medal for honorary
patronage from trinity college's
philosophical society
is that true or false
i don't i didn't know it was called that
it's just
this guy like a medallion i thought it
was a joke
i was like why am i getting any sort of
award but i didn't what was it called
what am i telling you this is awesome uh
the trinity college philosophical
society gold medal for literary
patronage well they were having a laugh
with me that's your shirt
oh man
oh that's so good i'd be so great if i
actually had it in my pocket like i take
it with me everywhere like you mean this
thing
you you should carry that around chris
tj will have we ever had have we ever
had us we've done this maybe a hundred
times at least right in our eight year
history or eight seven plus year history
have we ever had a celebrity
ask me to confirm the truth or a fact
is that the first time that's ever
happened easily now sean do you want do
you want to play trinity college true or
false how much about trinity college do
you know i know zero
it's in ireland right
no it's in hartford connecticut
what the dude i don't think i got that
award by the way it's honorary patronage
it's not the full-on page wait no no no
i never got that award i got something
from ireland
there is a trinity in ireland no see
all right last one because i definitely
need to know for sure last one uh
true or false
sean william scott you once helped
christopher walken celebrate his
birthday when it wasn't really his
birthday true or false
yeah that's a that's pretty true so
what's the story so i i was on the set
of the rundown which is great with the
rock great movie oh thank you not that i
had anything to do with it i'd love it
too though but and i remember seeing
christopher walken
he looked really sad i was like walking
to my trail and he was just kind of
what i remember he was like standing
outside his trailer he looked kind of
sad i can't do his voice but i remember
being like
oh hey christopher walken yeah i don't
know why i always called him his full
name it was like christopher walken
right because he's scared for a walk
because he's sad he goes
no no
well maybe a little bit you know it's my
birthday i'm like oh my god happy
birthday christopher walken that's
amazing and he goes no i don't i don't
make a big deal of it he's like you know
the thing is like
every year you know it's my birthday and
it's like this year you know i feel like
kind of alone
and
you know usually i get a cake i'm like
oh well let people know he's like
i'm just kidding it's not my birthday
but i bet you right now if i told people
they bring me out of cake i'm like what
and then like 10 50 minutes later i hear
the crew sing happy birthday to him and
i walk by him and he's like gives me a
wink i'm like
weirdo
and then like a couple days later he
came up to me and he goes hey do you
know where i could get a nice steam
and i was like
esteem i go yeah give me a second and i
went up to the rock i go
dude working walking get a steam he's
like what
i forget it and then i found out like a
spa
and i told him i go yeah there's a spa
like in beverly hills he goes do you
think there'd be a lot of really good
looking men there i go
what
and he kind of winked at me and just
walked away i'm like this guy's messing
with me
all the time
he was awesome
so it's true but you also got got a a
place where there's a good steam when
you're on steam yeah on a birthday it
really wasn't his birthday
fantastic his real birthday is next week
oh well you guys see him
[Laughter]
welcome to flash thursdays at 9 30 p.m
eastern time on fox great to see you
sean williams scott great to see you
thanks for having me
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here